Ciao Buonasera Buonasera a tutte e a
tutti
quando mia figlia aveva tre anni mi
ritrovai a fare una surreale
chiacchierata con il mio capo negli anni
mi ero occupata di elezioni europee
avevo scritto di crisi bancarie e titoli
indicizzati all'inflazione qualsiasi
cosa volesse dire
avevo viaggiato ovunque Parigi Londra
Bruxelles Seul Eppure da quando avevo
avuto mia figlia la giostra sera
all'improvviso fermata non ero più una
giornalista non ero più la prima
laureata in famiglia in generazioni di
De Cesare ferrovieri e contadini non ero
più Ecco lo avevo già capito in realtà
già dal primo giorno dopo il parto
quando medici e ginecologhe e pediatra
infermiere non avevano mai pronunciato
il mio nome solo mamma ma me ne accorsi
definitivamente nel corso di quella
chiacchierata con il mio capo quando
cercavo di spiegargli che stavo bene
potevo scrivere lavorare persino
viaggiare e lui mi rispose Ma io in
tutti questi anni ho cercato solo di
tutelarti E perché non lo hai fatto
anche con i padri
ecco quando parliamo di femminismo
parliamo spesso di soffitto di cristallo
gender Gap Poi certo anche delle Donne
che odiano gli uomini che non si
depilano e tutto L'allegro Carosello di
stupidi stereotipi ma non parliamo mai
di lavoro
molta gente conosce il femminismo
attraverso i mass media generalisti e
quello che ne ricava è parità di genere
pari retribuzione condivisione delle
faccende domestiche tutto sacrosanto
giustissimo ma belux ci ha insegnato che
è molto di più
la nostra indipendenza personale Passa
anche dalla nostra indipendenza
economica la famosa stanza tutta per noi
e il denaro Ma se il MoVimento femminile
si fosse dato come priorità il
miglioramento delle condizioni di lavoro
delle donne e avesse al contempo
garantito migliori retribuzioni e
accesso al mondo del lavoro da parte
delle donne di tutte le classi sociali
probabilmente il femminismo sarebbe
stato concepito come un movimento che si
prende carico dei problemi di tutte le
donne e invece diceva belux il
carrierismo la focalizzazione sulle
professioni altamente remunerative non
soltanto allontanato tantissime donne ma
ci ha fatto soprattutto credere illudere
che l'inserimento nel mondo del lavoro
di un gruppo di donne Borghesi
significava che le donne come gruppo
avevano ormai acquisito potere economico
Ma cosa volete ora siete dappertutto
è falso e continua ad essere falso
perché non ci siamo focalizzando su
un'esigenza fondamentale e collettiva
ripensare il lavoro
ogni giorno nel rullo delle notizie di
cronaca politica e attualità compare sui
quotidiani ogni tanto un nuovo supereroe
quasi come fosse un personaggio Marvel e
cosa fa questo nuovo supereroe di così
eccezionale È un imprenditore o un
amministratore delegato che dall'alto
del suo potere bontà sua decide di
assumere una donna Nonostante sia
incinta Nonostante sia in attesa di un
bambino Ecco la candidata Cosa fa in
fase di colloquio confessa di essere in
attesa perché la maternità si sa È un
peccato da assolvere e lui dall'alto del
suo potere decide di salvarla la assume
Ecco questo gesto in una società che ha
normalizzato la discriminazione sulle
donne si fa notizia arriva prima sulle
agenzie di stampa poi sui giornali
infine in televisione e trasforma un
questo ordinario la mancata
discriminazione in un gesto
straordinario
applausi eroe Ecco partiamo da qui e
parliamo anche del fatto che molto
spesso al posto del supereroe c'è una
super eroina c'è una donna che in certi
casi si comporta esattamente come gli
uomini
e anzi certe volte la candidata è
incinta Non la salva non la assume la
assume dopo i quattro giri di boa così
se doveva sposarsi si è già sposata se
doveva fare figli li ha già avuti se
doveva separarsi ha fatto pure quello
così può dedicarsi serenamente
pacatamente h24 al capitalismo Evviva
Quindi come vedete il lavoro non libera
le donne ancora oggi Anzi le condanna
spesso a una seconda gabbia La prima è
la casa dove molte volte devono
occuparsi soprattutto dei bisogni degli
altri gratuitamente la seconda gabbia è
proprio il lavoro dove Sempre se ci
arrivano Devono adattarsi a regole
modalità e poteri patriarcali Le
organizzazioni del lavoro spesso come
come sono concepite oggi prevedono
divisioni carierismo
profitto produttività a tutti i costi
Oltre alle immancabili discriminazioni
ma vedete il lavoro non libera neanche
gli uomini
gli uomini o almeno la stragrande
maggioranza di loro non ha tempo che per
il lavoro non ha tempo da dedicare ai
propri partner alla partner al partner
non ha tempo da dedicare ai figli non ha
tempo da dedicare alla propria
consapevolezza emotiva non ha tempo da
dedicare alla propria consapevolezza
sentimentale tant'è che poi i luoghi di
lavoro diventano luoghi dove le emozioni
sono bandite luoghi da performance dove
c'è una fortissima esibizione virile la
stessa esibizione virile che si trova
nelle riunioni dove le donne Infatti
fanno persino fatica a prendere la
parola
Ecco proprio così fanno fatica a
prendere la parola e tutto questo è
controproducente Eppure rientra nella
norma siamo infelici molto spesso sul
lavoro ma abbiamo normalizzato
l'insofferenza al lavoro e chi se ne
libera viene considerato pazzo
quando ho avuto il privilegio di poter
lasciare il giornale dove ho lavorato
per 15 anni molti colleghi mi hanno
definito coraggiosa Ma so Per certa che
appena girato l'angolo
confessavano ad altri che ormai non
c'era proprio alcun ombra di dubbio ero
pazza
i social ma soprattutto il femminismo mi
aveva dato alla testa parlavo di cose
strane
capitalismo assi di oppressione sessismo
razzismo omo lesbo transfobia e in
effetti sì io lì mi sentivo totalmente
fuori posto
pazza e quello che mi ha detto un
collega mentre ci scambiavamo dei
messaggi su WhatsApp e gli stavo
raccontando cosa cosa stessi facendo
gli ho risposto con una faccina
ironicamente gli ho detto Beh se
vogliamo cambiare un po' il mondo è
necessaria una sana dose di follia ma la
sua risposta è stata rivelatrice a me il
mondo va bene così era Comodamente
seduto sul suo privilegio
Comodamente seduto sul suo privilegio
ecco
Io sono partita da me stessa per cercare
di cambiare il mio lavoro
no
pensate che
soltanto il 20% degli articoli è scritto
da una donna e questo cosa significa che
lo sguardo maschile Domina su tutto
anche sulla selezione delle notizie
le donne pur essendo grandissime
lettrici di libri per esempio non
leggono i quotidiani non si informano
sui giornali perché non si vedono non si
sentono rappresentate
e questo è un grave problema
la rappresentazione del mondo come tale
e opera dell'uomo egli lo descrive dal
suo punto di vista che confonde come la
verità assoluta diceva Simon de beauvoir
ed è così ancora oggi
cosa ho fatto io per cercare di cambiare
il sistema e di cambiare le cose lottare
ma farlo da fuori perché come diceva
oltre Lord gli strumenti del padrone non
smantelleranno mai la casa del padrone
oppure sempre per toccarla a pianissimo
citando Carla lonzi solo chi è fuori
dalla dicotomia soggetto padrone potrà
introdurre nel mondo il soggetto
imprevisto e il mio soggetto imprevisto
si chiama depiriod
depiriod.it che è il mio progetto
editoriale la mia newsletter la mia
community ma soprattutto il mio punto è
a capo nella narrazione dei fatti lo
dicevamo Prima no la rappresentazione
del mondo le donne che non si vedono nei
giornali che leggono o se si vedono se
si vedono rappresentate sono sempre come
donne sessualizzate vittime oppure mamme
la mammezzazione di cui parlavamo
all'inizio e quindi sei giornalista Ma
sei soprattutto madre sei astronauta Ma
sei soprattutto madre sei una scienziata
Ma sei soprattutto madre
perché evidenziare che i ruoli di potere
ci è arrivata una madre confortante ci
fa pensare che l'attitudine materna sia
l'ittitudine principale delle donne
e che quell'attenzione quella cura che
quella empatia sarà applicata anche al
loro agire professionale
si chiama sessismo e spoiler ne
troverete abbondante traccia nei media
generalisti quello che non troverete è
invece laprofobia la paura che abbiamo
costante della povertà e dei poveri la
transfobia
inesistente non troverete non troverete
una riflessione approfondita sul ruolo
istituzionalizzato che hanno nella
nostra società il razzismo e il sessismo
ma mettere in crisi il capitalismo
Grazie Silvia Federici è fondamentale
così come è fondamentale lottare
battersi contro le disuguaglianze e le
discriminazioni che ci sono abbondanti
nella nostra società come abbiamo visto
anche oggi
e quindi il tema è che molto spesso si
cerca il cambiamento sempre dagli altri
mai da se stessi Io sono partita dal mio
lavoro perché nelle redazioni dei
giornali e dei media in generale ci sono
molto spesso maschi Bianchi etero CIS
non troverete giornalisti appartenenti
alla comunità marginalizzate non
troverete giornalisti che sono anche
persone con disabilità e questo badate
bene Non solo in Italia anche all'estero
pensate che in Germania dove un quarto
della popolazione e così è costituito da
persone migranti o con un passato
migratorio la loro presenza tra i
giornalisti è appena del 4%
l'industria media britannica e per il 94
94% bianca
con una presenza della comunità
musulmana e della comunità dei neri che
si aggira tra i giornalisti tra il 2 e
il 4%, questo Cosa significa che le
differenze di cultura etnia religione
sesso genere vengono invisibilizzate nei
processi di selezione delle notizie
oppure peggio ancora diventano elementi
stigmatizzanti nei titoli e nei pezzi a
dando ad alimentare
il razzismo e il sessismo endemico della
nostra società
ci sono tantissime giornaliste donne è
vero nelle redazioni anche in Italia ci
sono anche tante giornaliste di potere
molto spesso però sono come le eroine di
cui parlavamo all'inizio molto spesso
esercitano il potere alla maniera
maschile non cambiando nulla
altrettanto spesso invece le giornaliste
quelle che non ce l'hanno quel potere
vengono invisibilizzate
Ma come Mi disse un giorno in
un'intervista Susanna Camusso Noi donne
non siamo minoranza siamo minorizzate in
diversi aspetti della nostra società
Ed è ora di mettere un punto e a capo
Grazie
[Applauso]